air fryers have become super popular the
last few years
they're great because they're energy
efficient they cook foods fast
and they're really easy to use i mean
you can cook just about
anything in them from beautifully brown
vegetables to crispy skin chicken wings
even lightenery cakes it only takes a
small amount of oil
to cook delicious food today we're going
to be focusing on air frying
savory foods tasty 101 air fryers
so what is an air fryer first of all
they're ovens
not fryers they're basically these mini
powerful conduction ovens their key
element
is having fans that blow hot air in
circulation
so the temperature is equalized
throughout the oven this hot air
circulation surrounds the food
cooking it evenly and quickly because of
this air fryers require
little to no oil compared to deep frying
while there are many air fryers on the
market
they generally fall into two categories
basket air fryers and convection oven
air fryers
the basket air fryers are the most
popular with a basket
similar to a deep fryer to hold the food
both will achieve similar results
before we get started here are some
basic tips to keep in mind no matter
what you're cooking
it's important that you give your
machine enough space on all sides to
account for proper airflow
a good rule of thumb is to allow five
inches of clearance on all sides
and make sure your surfaces are heat
proof you don't want to cook with an air
fryer that's pushed against a wall
always have the grate in the basket this
allows hot air to circulate around the
food
and also keeps the food from sitting in
excess oil if you have a wire rack for
your air fryer
use it it helps the food stay crispy on
the bottom
really takes things to the next level
just trust us
it's always good to preheat the air
fryer for about two to three minutes and
then you're good to go
it's also helpful to use a non-aerosol
oil spray to help prevent sticking
and to keep your foods nice and crispy
now we're going to go over four popular
foods you'll cook in an air fryer
foods with a dry batter foods with the
wet batter
batterless foods and frozen foods our
first recipe is going to be a dry batter
with coconut shrimp we have a little
secret to the perfect shrimp
that secret is buttermilk we're going to
marinate the shrimp and buttermilk for
30 minutes
this helps to tenderize the shrimp so
they don't overcook in the air fryer
this technique also works great for
chicken pork or even steaks
but first we need to season the shrimp
in a small bowl we're going to stir
together the salt
pepper garlic powder and paprika we're
going to place the shrimp on a cutting
board and pat dry with paper towels
then we'll season the shrimp on both
sides with our spice mixture
we're using jumbo shrimp that's been
peeled and deveined the bigger the
shrimp the better to prevent overcooking
we'll add our seasoned shrimp to a bowl
with the buttermilk and lime zest
then we're going to let it marinate for
about 30 minutes we're using lime zest
to go with the caribbean coconut theme
but feel free to emit if you don't have
them
now we're going to preheat the air fryer
to 380 degrees fahrenheit
we have our flour eggs and panko in
three separate bowls
now we're going to add the coconut
flakes to the bread crumbs and we'll
stir it to combine
you can also substitute panko with bread
crumbs chips pretzels or crackers
now we're gonna remove the shrimp from
the marinade and we'll gently shake it
to get off any excess buttermilk
we're simply coating the shrimp in a
thin layer of flour and shaking off any
of the excess
next we'll dip the floured shrimp into
the beaten egg wash
make sure the eggs are really well
beaten so it evenly coats the shrimp
this helps the main coating stick to the
food for our final step
breading now we'll dredge it once again
into the panko mixture
we're going to add half the shrimp to
the airfryer so it's not overcrowded
we'll spray it with the non-aerosol
oil spray and cook for about three
minutes then
we're gonna flip spray the tops and cook
for another one to two minutes or until
they're nice and crispy
if the shrimp's tail is pink that's a
good sign it's cooked now let's remove
them from the basket and repeat with our
remaining shrimp
it's important not to overcrowd your air
fryer you don't want the shrimp to steam
you want it to get real crispy now serve
it with your favorite dipping sauce and
some lime wedges
this dredge method works for onion rings
mozzarella sticks
chicken nuggets chicken tenders avocado
fries
zucchini fries let your creativity take
over and dredge away
for our wet batter recipe we're going to
air fry buffalo cauliflower wings
first we'll preheat the air fryer to 430
degrees fahrenheit for about five
minutes
now we noticed that our different air
fryers go up to different temperatures
so you might just have to keep an eye on
it and maybe your food needs to cook for
a little bit longer
now we're gonna mix together our cake
flour corn starch
baking powder smoked paprika garlic
powder
onion powder and a half teaspoon of salt
we're using cake flour because it has a
lower protein content which prevents a
bready crust
you might also notice we're not using
eggs in this wet batter
that's because when we tested it it
resulted in a cakey batter and to be
honest it wasn't that great
now slowly stir in the sparkling water
when sparkling water is added to a
batter
its bubbles create pockets of air that
give the final product a beautiful light
texture
once again the most important part of
this is in the mixing
when combining the ingredients do not
over mix the batter
it is also vital to prepare the batter
right before cooking
this gives the flour as little time as
possible to soak up water
giving you maximum crispiness now we're
going to toss the cauliflower florets
with the remaining corn starch and salt
cauliflower releases water when it's
cooked and that can lead to a soggy
crust
the corn starch catches that water and
prevents it from ruining the batter
this will help you get that beautiful
golden color and classic crunchiness
make sure to shake off any excess
cornstarch then dip into the wet batter
and let any excess drip off place the
cauliflower in a single layer and cook
for about five minutes or until nice and
golden brown work in batches
and remember never overcrowd the
airfryer with too much food
once nice and golden brown remove the
cauliflower from the air fryer and
repeat with the remaining florets
while your cauliflower is cooking let's
make the sauce we're gonna mix together
some hot sauce
butter and honey and we're gonna cook it
stirring it occasionally
until it's just heated through the
butter is melted and it's evenly
combined
now let's toss the cauliflower wings
with the buffalo sauce and enjoy
immediately no really it's actually the
best eaten right away or it can get too
soggy
this method works with any kind of
vegetable or protein sweet potatoes
asparagus
green beans no batter no problem
balsamic chicken thighs to the rescue
start by generously seasoning the
chicken thighs with salt on both sides
and make sure to go under the skin
there's nothing worse than under
seasoned food seriously
don't be alarmed by the amount of salt
we're about to use then whisk together
the dijon
balsamic olive oil garlic powder and
italian seasoning
we're going to add the seasoned chicken
thighs to the marinade and toss to coat
them completely
then we'll cover and refrigerate for at
least four hours but preferably
overnight let the chicken come to room
temperature before you start cooking
preheat the air fryer to 380 degrees
fahrenheit for about three minutes
now we'll remove the chicken from our
marinade and we'll pat them dry with
paper towels
this will help get the chicken super
crispy adding a spritz of non-aerosol
cooking spray or a drizzle of olive oil
to your food before air frying will give
you nice browning and crispiness
add as many chicken thighs as will fit
skin side down and cook for five to
seven minutes
we're cooking the chicken thighs skin
side down so the skin can start to
render the fat without browning the skin
too much
flip the chicken so the skin side is up
and cook for an additional
five to seven minutes until the internal
temperature reaches 165 degrees
fahrenheit
repeat with any remaining chicken thighs
if you need to this method can also be
done with buffalo chicken wings
meatballs salmon whole roasted chicken
or steak there may be no batter in this
method but it is a
home run now here are some quick tips
for air frying frozen foods
because of the popularity of the air
fryer some frozen foods now conveniently
have instructions for using the
appliance right on the package
but if they don't the rule of thumb is
to use the same temperature as you would
in an oven
but cut the cooking time in half so if
the instructions on the package
recommend 20 minutes at 400 degrees you
should only cook it for about 10 minutes
at 400 degrees in an air fryer give the
basket nice shimmy and shake halfway
through the cooking to redistribute the
food
and give it a chance to brown and crisp
up evenly in general
we found that foods fried in the
airfryer are significantly better when
eaten while hot
they tend to harden up a bit as they
cool much like foods cooked in more
traditional ways
but in a more pronounced way now here's
some quick reminders and cleaning tips
remember that with air fryers food cooks
way faster than you're used to it's one
of its best attributes
you can reference your fryer's manual
but in general the less food in the
basket the shorter the cook time will be
the more food the longer it will be it's
pretty straightforward
by the way if you're trying to figure
out sizing here's a quick cheat sheet
in general if you're cooking for more
people you should invest in a bigger
frying basket
but if you're cooking solo just invest
in something small if you're cooking
greasy food in your air fryer
don't be surprised if you see some smoke
don't stress it
just place a slice of bread in the
bottom of the unit to soak up any excess
grease
clean the basket after every use just
with some soap and water and a gentle
sponge
it's a non-stick cooking surface so you
don't want to use a scratchy sponge
if you have any hard to clean stuck on
messes just sprinkle with baking soda
and let it sit for like five minutes
then use a sponge to wipe it clean so
next time you're thinking of reheating
food in the microwave
how about using the air fryer for crispy
and tasty leftovers
there you have it air fryers are pretty
versatile and easy to use
i hope that this has been helpful to you
and maybe give one of these recipes a
fry
[Music]
you